♪♪
Hi guys!
I am Krys Marshall,
I play Danielle Poole
on For All Mankind.
And today you guys
are in for a total treat,
because I am gonna
give you a tour
of the NASA HAB...
AKA...
The Happy Valley.
First thing's up is
our very cool
computer system here.
This is where
you will see our
astronauts receive phone calls
and video calls from home.
This very archaic piece
of equipment is early FaceTime.
As we continue back
you’ll see there’s
bunks here, however...
if we have more
than eight astronauts
then we actually
sleep in shifts.
They call that “hot racking”
in the biz.
This is our tunnel
which leads to the
next half of the HAB.
Our crew has done
an immaculate job
of building our sets
so they feel
really real.
Very sturdy.
Little secret here;
there was an earthquake
in the middle of the take.
I went...
[laughs]
Come through this way.
We have our airlock.
So you’ll see that
each of these
separate sections are
kind of like
these massive chambers.
God forbid there is a leak,
we can shut off the chamber
and the thing stays
vacuum sealed,
like, high quality
tupperware.
Come on down this way guys.
Here, we will have spare tires,
we got batteries, we got
everything that one needs
for life on Mars.
This is the — maybe the
most important door
in the whole,
entire Mars HAB
because on
the other side...
That’s not just the
miracle of T.V.
that’s real.
We’re heading to the galley.
There are foods
and knick-knacks
and MRE's
which is short for
meals ready to eat.
We enjoy some really
delicious things here.
Things like: gelatinous meat,
meat stew, meat slivers,
meat slices,
so really, really vile
things that we eat here.
But, we also do our
science experiments here
and things like that.
This is our seismograph.
This tells us what’s going on
on the surface of Mars here.
The last and final
space, which is
very dear to my heart
because it’s the only
living thing—truly
living thing here,
other than the
astronauts and cosmonauts —
our garden.
Or as we like to call it,
“The Swamp.”
We’re growing
some gorgeous
red-vine tomatoes
and kale
and dark leafy greens
and things like that.
And on that note,
it’s been nice
having ya.
Ta-ta for now.
♪♪